W'll start by rewriting 9 16ths as 3 squared divided by 4 squared. We can do
this since we know 3 squared is 9 and 4 squared is 16. Next, we're going to
pull out our exponent of 2 from each part of the fraction. So we'll just have 3
4ths raised to the 2nd power. Now again, I'm so close to having these bases
match. I have 4 3rds here, but I have 3 4ths here. In order to get these two
bases to match, we need to flip this base. So, we'll use a negative exponent to
do that. So, 3 4ths squared is the same thing as 4 3rds raised to the negative
second power. Remember, this negative 1, or this exponent of negative 1, flips
over our base. Now we have two bases that are the same, so we can set the
exponents equal. X must equal negative 2.